there are days when I'll be checking out
some awesome Android app when I run into
an anti-pattern it's pure anti Android
and which totally destroys the magic and
I'm all alike
well my team is sick of me making a mess
of their workspace so I'm channeling my
energy into something more productive
welcome to table flip today I'm
returning the topic of one of my
earliest Android UX rats exit menu items
back in the days before time began when
humans typed into terminal prompts and
were huddled in dark caves googling
Wikipedia for fire single tasking
operating systems like ms-dos allowed us
to run one app at a time
exit was unambiguous a necessity for
leaving what happened starting another
instruction itself had semantic meaning
exit mapped to the C function exit which
terminated the calling process as we
crawled from our hidden caves hunting
the last of the wooly mammoth
multitasking operating systems like
Windows enabled us to run multiple
programs at once each represented by its
own window as before our exit menu item
is used to call exit to terminate the
process and allow us to reclaim the
resources used by the task window having
grown fat and complacent with
multitasking operating systems gorging
on a glut of RAM and CPU resources
provided by Moore's Law smart phones
introduced a new challenge how to create
responsive multitasking operating
systems with a fraction of the resources
well unlike windowed operating systems
smartphones generally present apps
fullscreen and one at a time so it's
easy to establish a relative priority
between applications
following androids Three Laws of
Robotics 1 whichever app is in the
foreground must have the resources it
needs to run and run responsibly to any
application with a visible activity or a
running service should be allowed to run
except when doing so would be in
violation of the first law and 3 any
application without a visible activity
or a running service should be kept in
memory to reduce startup latency except
when doing so would be in violation of
the first or second laws much as a
sonam's three laws were built into
positronic brains so to have androids
laws been baked into the platform
this has three implications for app
design firstly knowing that the OS can
terminate your apps process without
warning at any time you can't rely on
having a non exit handler that will be
called whenever your app is closed
instead your activities should listen
for on pause
handlers that indicate that your app is
no longer active at this point it may be
terminated at any time so it should save
any user data to prevent potential data
loss when your activity is no longer
visible it'll receive a non-stop handler
a good app will treat this handler as
the equivalent of a non exit handler
reducing its resource usage as much as
possible we already know that the
background apps the low priority so they
should consume the absolute minimum in
terms of resources even without the
system having to terminate them doing so
will increase the chances of your app
remaining running thereby decreasing
startup time and improving its
responsiveness so thanks to the three
laws your app doesn't need an exit
button well what's the harm in having
one anyway why do these seemingly
insignificant UI elements fill me with a
dark and fiery rage that burns as
intensely as the heart of a neutron star
where does that anger go well I bottle
up my emotions into a dark fist of
psychic hate that I can harness and
unleash anon weary foes and an exit menu
item in Android has no semantic wide
system meaning so including one in your
app actually introduces ambiguity
consider the Google apps that typically
ship with most Android devices
imagine if Gmail the gallery in the
contacts app all had exit buttons what
would you expect them to do chances are
you've never looked for an exit button
in any of these apps and have never been
disappointed that it's not there if you
build an application that properly
handles that state transitions its
predictable that's configural and it's
unambiguous your users won't ask for an
exit button but what about apps like
music navigation or even banking apps
whose background behaviors can demand
stronger user messages from them we need
an explicit exit button but fortunately
that's exactly what the back buttons
does on Android when you use a presses
back the activity calls finish
explicitly destroying the activity and
freeing its resources making it a
functional equivalent to the exit button
in days of yore for most apps it makes
little difference if the user is exiting
explicitly or switching to another app
but in some cases this additional signal
can be useful apps like movies or music
players don't need this signal as they
already show their use of semantic
controls to determine ongoing behavior a
music player for example should keep
rocking out until you pause playback
turn-by-turn navigation though has no
simple cues in this rare example it can
be useful to
interpretive back button presses an
explicit request to end all route
guidance some apps such as instant
messaging banking or remote terminal
sessions may need a way to terminate the
current session whether it be for
security or resource usage reasons
rather than using the simp antic
semantically ambiguous exit menu item
it's better practice to include a menu
item that describes exactly what will
happen such as logout sign out or a
similarly descriptive action for users
who want to take the proverbial shotgun
to the head of zombie background apps
they can force stop a process from the
app setting as well as swiping to remove
apps from the application switcher on
newer Android platform releases I'm
nearly done but I can already hear the
fevered tapping of fingers on keyboard -
some of you prepare your own retaliatory
rants railing against my arrogance at
the presumption of knowing what users
want better than themselves I know from
having been told that yes many app
developers will still receive requests
to add an exit button to their apps
generally so that users can
unambiguously prevent the app from
consuming any resources I understand the
perspective but expecting the developer
of an app which doesn't properly manage
its resources to manage them correctly
simply by adding an exit button
introduces a certain level of cognitive
dissonance in the developer can't manage
their resources effectively without an
exit button what reason do you have to
believe that they will handle their
resources more effectively just because
they include one if your users are still
asking for an exit button it's generally
because they believe your app is
consuming resources when it shouldn't be
adding an exit button may give them a
temporary feeling of hope but it will be
quickly extinguished by a swamp of Tears
and recrimination when the ambiguity of
their new exit' option becomes apparent
what should happen to services when a
user hits a exit what about intent
receivers widgets should you stop
listening to GCM messages different
users will have different expectations
and satisfying some will frustrate
others the best solution is to obviate
their perceived need for an exit button
by following these simple steps start by
freeing resources stopping services
disabling sensor listeners and turning
off the location requests and otherwise
disabling anything that consumes
resources all within the on pause
handler of your activities take this a
step further by avoiding Singleton's and
custom application objects within your
application
whenever possible if your resources are
tied to an activity they'll be freed
when the user hits the back button
rather than having to wait until the
application process itself is terminated
another culprit for resource consumption
is an app that sets alarms to wake the
device and pull for updates on a regular
basis
you can improve your apps battery drain
profile by making these alarms inexact
and allowing the user to specify the
frequency of these background updates
but every time you ping a server when
there was nothing to update you're not
only draining the battery from the
device being on you're also draining the
battery by turning on the cell radio for
no good reason Google Cloud messaging
allows you to eliminate all polling so
you only pin your server when you know
that you have information worth
downloading if your app doesn't require
if your app does require a way of
signing out or logging off create an
explicit semantically meaningful way of
doing so rather than relying in an
ambiguous legacy exit command music apps
are the most common example of an app
that should continue running at a high
priority even when there is no activity
visible however where no music is
playing the app is no different to any
other background app when it is playing
make sure it's easy to stop rich
notifications and widgets should provide
easy shortcuts to stop playback at which
point you should free your resources in
exactly the same way as a typical app
within our on pause Alon stop handles
finally the Android OS provides a number
of cues of significant system events
including low battery and low memory
listen for these intents and modify your
resource usage of your app accordingly
users only ask you to include an exit
button if they blame your app for
consuming memory draining the battery or
otherwise deteriorating their overall
experience rather than implementing a
menu item that won't solve their
underlying problem spend your time
making your app more efficient and more
responsive my name is reto Meier
this was tableflip